immer mal wieder gibt es schlagzeilen zu
tutanchamuns grab und das wäre wohl die
entdeckung des jahrhunderts ein
forschungsteam aus italien hat hinweise
darauf gefunden dass direkt neben
tutanchamuns grab eine oder sogar
mehrere bislang unbekannte grabkammern
existieren könnten
frühere untersuchungen hatten darin
sogar die mumie seiner stiefmutter
nofretete vermutet wow
wie konkret die aktuellen
forschungsergebnisse wirklich sind und
ob sie das rätsel um die grabkammer des
großen ägyptischen pharaos jetzt lüften
jetzt index um science-fiction herzlich
willkommen schon seit 3400 jahren ist
der pharao tutanchamun tod und unter der
erde vergraben seiner grabstätte wurde
noch seit 22 entdeckt und obwohl das
schon so lange her ist ist das tal der
könige immer mal wieder eine schlagzeile
wert zuletzt noch im sommer 2015 als ein
britischer archäologe verkündete das ist
hinter einer glaswand des pharaos
weitere räume gelbe linien strukturen
name als hinweise und auf den aufnahmen
der nördlichen und westlichen kann warnt
der grabkammer wollte er vermehrte
durchgänge erkannt haben und nicolas ri
setzte damals noch einen drauf denn
hinter diesen wänden sei wohl die mumie
von tutanchamuns stiefmutter nofretete
zu finden nicht wenige witterten eine
sensation es gab pressekonferenzen ohne
ende
zusätzliche bodenuntersuchungen eines
reha spezialisten aus japan machten
weitere hoffnung denn auch seine
messungen ergaben hinweise darauf dass
möglicherweise zwei weitere unbekannte
räumen existieren könnten
langwierige und aufwendige radler
messung eines forschungsteams im auftrag
von national geographic sollten dann den
endgültigen beweis liefern
doch der blieb aus und das obwohl mehr
als 40 stunden lang 40 1 gemacht worden
sind und das in zwei verschiedenen
frequenzen doch der scan im tal der
könige schien sogar der sensation zu
widersprechen das damalige
forschungsteam war sich am ende sicher
unentdeckte kann man also hohlräume
müssten eine starke reflexion liefern
und die blieb aus
jetzt gibt es neues futter rund um das
grab von tutanchamun ein italienisches
forschungsteam von der universität turin
hat jetzt wohl anomalien
angrenzend an das fahrrad gefunden und
zwar zwei stück links und rechts von
tutanchamuns grabkammer das hätten
drohnen bilder gezeigt mit der sie die
grabstätte gescannt hat darauf sei eine
sowohl links als auch rechts von der
grabkammer eine rote fläche zu sehen
links etwas größer als rechts auch die
fläche unmittelbar neben der kammer
weise anomalien auf so der ehemalige
antik minister ägyptens mam duell dabei
wir können leider noch nicht sagen was
diese anomalien bedeuten auf die frage
ob es sich vielleicht tatsächlich um die
grabkammer von königin nofretete handelt
sagte nur weiter
während wissenschaftler und keine
spekulanten weitere untersuchungen
bräuchten zeit und könnten dann
gewissheit geben doch sein begriff der
anomalie hinterlässt tatsächlich ein
großes fragezeichen denn damit könnte
theoretisch gesehen natürlich alles oder
nichts gemein sein ein hohlraum ein loch
oder doch eine unbekannte kammer bislang
sind diese neuen ergebnisse des
italienischen forschungsteams jedenfalls
noch nicht in einem wissenschaftlichen
fachjournal zu finden
im laufe des jahres 2018 soll dann von
innen weiter gescannt werden und zwar
mit hilfe eines bodenradar was am kit
ministerium ergebnis betont an dieser
stelle aber immer wieder dass lediglich
ein punkt die höchste priorität habe und
zwar die unversehrtheit des bauwerks und
erst wenn gewissheit darüber herrsche
dass es einen weiteren bislang
unbekannten raum gibt würden bohrungen
erlaubt werden dann könnte nämlich eine
kamera eingeführt werden und uns den
fall der fälle
beweisfotos liefern es bleibt also
weiter sehr sehr spannend was sein
ergibt noch alles auftaucht erst vor
kurzem gab es ja aktuelle entdeckung von
mumien monumenten und einem hohlraum in
der cheops pyramide an dieser stelle
vielen dank an alle die meine aussprache
korrigiert haben wenn ihr kein video zum
thema und auch zu allen anderen themen
verpassen wollt dann drückt mir hier ein
abo aufs auge und vergessen nicht den
genau auf die glocke nur dann werdet ihr
auch immer wieder über neue videos
informiert wenn sie erscheinen und hier
geht es weiter mit dafür draufklicken
geheime kammer der cheops-pyramide
entdeckt ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran